this is the reality for many ukrainians
still left in the country's second
largest city
shelled by russian forces whilst they
slept
emergency services stretched to capacity
as shells rain down in the middle of the
night our night starts with police as
they patrol the streets on the lookout
for what they say are russian saboteurs
we've been given access to this special
unit of the police force that patrolled
the city past curfew
making sure there's no threats behind
those front lines
reassuring people that the police are
still operating
and taking care of kharkiv
but nothing has prepared them for what
they are doing now
this is my first time at war i haven't
experienced anything like this before
i've been to donetsk in luhansk but what
i've experienced here has shocked me
we work with the people we detained
looters we caught saboteurs
we never did anything like this if we
were not guarding the rear it would be
difficult for the ukrainian military on
the front line
we come across a burning house
the constant third from russian
artillery is ever present
let's go let's go
then we see a flash of light in the sky
look incoming he shouts
the police arrive on the scene
so the shell is just hit
the police have arrived
they're letting people know that they're
here and making sure everybody is okay
[Music]
quiet quiet he says it's going to be
okay we're here now
across the street windows were blown out
are you alive she shouts
yes comes a reply i'm alive
it could have been far worse
police hear reports of another building
being hit
we're the first there
it's unclear if there are any casualties
the shocked survivors leave the block of
flats
my mom and dad need to get out of there
can somebody call them
the police tried to distract the
children and make them feel better
a moment of laughter amongst the madness
that ensues around them
one woman refuses to go to the
underground station used as a bomb
shelter
this is her home
the explosion hit my wife was thrown out
of the bed we came out and the entrance
was on fire
more buildings burn
suddenly there's more incoming shelling
we make a run for it
but for the people who live here
there is no escape
they face being hit by russian
bombardment at any time
and any place
al-jazeera
well let's speak live to assad bake now
who is still in kharkiv i said
i mean it's it's really something to see
that package your piece there seeing
what people really are going through
in the city with russia announcing its
next phase what can the people of khaki
expect
well there's a real fear here that
there's going to be a renewed offensive
as russia announces that it wants to
liberate as they call it the donbass
region which is in the east of the
country now if they do that if they
regroup and there is this new phase the
city could see a more intense situation
now it's already intense as it is we
can't keep up with the amount of places
that are getting shelled or hit by
missiles the artillery so these people
could face a very very difficult
situation but also it's strategic for
russia they want to secure the donbass
region they want to secure mario pole
and a land corridor a land bridge to the
crimea peninsula which they unexpect in
2014 but also some experts believe that
they want to cut off the bulk of the
ukrainian military that's in the east
around 50 000 of the ukrainian military
fighting there to encircle them and that
would mean taking karaki and working
their way down now if that happens the
ukrainian forces will be cut off but the
real fear is is that what the city has
already left but if the russians have a
new defensive intensify the shelling and
try to take the city it could result in
a real difficult humanitarian situation
for the people still remaining
all right thank you for that update
there's a big line for us in kharkiv